the hospital over Christmas was [ __ ]
suck yeah let's talk about that it is
lupus thing again right yeah are you
working too much still are you going out
of too hard and why everybody says that
you've been saying that for years when
you experienced near death situations
life-threatening situations its honors
is real I feel like I'm running out of
time when every time I think I'm doing
good then I got to go back to the
[ __ ] Hospital and feared almost died
this time but the blood clots and six I
don't fear it I welcome you I got to a
space now where's I that's just it's
probably going to have I'm probably
going to die sooner than most people and
that and because might mean that's what
that's what the doctor said but I'm
living life like the wooded like I might
die in the morning so let's talk all
night like what it does get right well
then I got a point why we're having a
mock neck the doctors have said to you
Nick when he gets serious could you die
a very young man dead I like in your
forties yeah Samir I mean if this will
progressed this what you got to realize
like the five blood transfusions will
because like if they didn't do that I
would have died yeah the blood clots
from the last time I was in the hospital
doctor literally said to me I can't I
don't understand how you're still alive
oh like you have I didn't do like you
have to blood clots in your lung and one
in your heart like okay but I think what
if the doctors are wrong and now you're
a 90 year old man with a hundred kids
like Joe and bring the Bible don't is
baby the way I'm supposed to die in my
part and I got a bankrupt